well and I think that what's interesting
is you know people forget that these
securities started out looking very
different right so when equity was first
you know created and somebody said I'll
give you money to run this company it
wasn't for enterprise value to then go
public or to be acquired it was
literally a claim on cash flows right
and so that it's almost like we're
coming full circle to some degree with
you know all this Unchained governance
or claim to you know transaction fees
etc in the blockchain world how much of
that do you think can be solved by
technology versus the psychology that's
a really great point and I think that's
probably a great way to summarize what I
just spent five minutes articulating so
I think what's interesting here is you
have a lot of people a lot of the people
in the crypto space who are working on
these ideas tend to be younger I think a
lot of them haven't worked in corporate
structures before and that's not a bad
thing there's a lot of value in
experimentation and innovation because
you can learn things that can be applied
at scale I think the challenge here is
is that the learning process has gotten
a bit bastardized because we are
building things that are highly
imperfect that are very flawed in a lot
of different ways both from a technical
perspective governments perspective and
actual scalability and implementation
perspective the practical application
perspective yet these projects are being
capitalized at valuations that exceed
the average IPO by a factor of 10 yep
right and so I think we kind of have
created this false sense of success
where people feel hey I'm able to raise
a [ __ ] ton of capital it's literally
shit-ton and they have no plan on how to
deploy it and I think the interesting
conversation I had with founders is one
of the things I've been focused on is
helping people with treasury management
is um there's a difference between need
and want right so maybe I need 50
million dollars to build this idea but
the market wants to give me five hundred
million so what do you do yeah exactly
in black chains don't change human
nature right there's a lot of ego
involved
this crypto environment right now the
narrative is so focused on price and how
much money was raised that we're kind of
getting to that stage where I think the
money needs to get flushed out of it and
we need to go back to building and this
goes right along with Carlota Perez is
research around capital formation
bubbles and how that corresponds with
technical innovation cycles but a lot of
this is we have this technology but can
we articulate a clear reason that this
technology needs to be utilized for
things that we already do in the
existing world and I think that
narrative just isn't there yet